MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
(Guten Abend! Ich bin Manu
vom Cabaret DivertiMento.)
(Wir haben uns einquartiert ...)
* Klopfen * (Der andere kommt auch.)
(Komm rein! Komm rein!)
(Wir sind im Hotel.)
(Wir haben soeben die letzte Show
von "Sabbatical" gespielt.)
(Und jetzt haben wir ...)
- (Wo hast du es?)
(Genau, wir schauen uns
den Film über Schottland an.)
(Vor einem Jahr
waren wir unterwegs.)
(Ich freue mich,
es noch mal zu schauen.)
(Wir haben es seither
nicht mehr gesehen.)
(Es schwingt etwas Nostalgie mit.
Komm!)
(Wir haben es noch nie
gemeinsam angeschaut.)
Ein Lauf, ein Gang
in etwas Unbekanntes.
Das hatten wir lange nicht mehr.
Wohin?
Seit 14 Jahren sind wir als Komiker
zusammen und haben viel erlebt.
Aber so etwas? Nein!
- Mir ist der Humor vergangen.
Wir waren in Schottland wandern,
auf dem West Highland Way.
Und zwar nicht nur zum Spass.
Das Ziel der Reise ist,
dass wir uns wieder näherkommen,
dass diese Freundschaft
wieder menschlicher wird
und weniger beruflich.
Drei Wochen, 150 km,
draussen bei Wind und Wetter.
Es ist auf jeden Fall härter,
als wir dachten.
* Stöhnen *
Es war eine anstrengende,
aber auch schöne Zeit.
Klar ausserhalb unserer Komfortzone.
Und genau das hat dieses Abenteuer
so einzigartig gemacht.
Das ist "SRF bi de Lüt".
"DivertiMento bei den Schotten".
Also ...
- Los geht's!
Endlich, wir kommen.
Ab die Post!
Bäh,
wie viele haben das schon gemacht?
Let's go!
- Adieu miteinander.
Enjoy!
- Thank you, thank you.
("Thank you, thank you" - du hast
doch nichts verstanden, Fischer!)
(Hier sind wir gestartet,
in Glasgow.)
(150 km, Fischer!)
* Er lacht. *
(Wo war das Ziel?)
(Äh, Dings ... Fort William.)
- (Fort William.)
* "These Boots Are Made For Walking"
von Nancy Sinatra *
(Kaum waren wir losgelaufen,
mussten wir schon ...)
Oh!
- Endlich!
Ah, tut das gut!
(Pinkelpause.)
Und Beinbruch!
- Ja, mit dem Rucksack.
Also, jetzt.
- Vamos!
Wo kann man die Hände waschen?
* "These Boots Are Made For Walking"
von Nancy Sinatra *
Das ist spannend.
"Anfang des 19. Jh. spielte der
dichte Wald vor den Toren Glasgows
eine gewisse Rolle ..."
Merkst du eigentlich, dass ich hier
im Dreck laufe und du im Trockenen?
Ich lese!
Ich bin Tageschef. Also bitte!
Ich laufe im Dreck.
- Jonny, bitte! Du musst dich fügen.
(Es gab ja noch
die Sache mit dem Tageschef.)
(Einer durfte einen Tag lang sagen,
wo es durchgeht,
wann Pausen anstehen.)
(Mit Wettbewerben
haben wir bestimmt, wer das ist.)
(Ja, das war nicht nur einfach.)
* Lachen *
* Sanfte Musik:
"Cargill" von King Creosote *
(Ha, unsere Crew!)
(Lachend) Schafseckel!
Schafseckel!
* Sanfte Musik:
"Cargill" von King Creosote *
* Lachen *
Ist aber schon geil.
- Megaschön.
Ich meine,
weil ich den Rucksack abgelegt habe.
Ist das ein Moor?
- Das ist Moor, wegen der Farbe.
Torfmull kommt von hier.
- Was du nicht alles weisst!
Was möchtest du? The bread?
- Ja, gerne, ich mache ein Sandwich.
Ich habe mir fest vorgenommen,
auf diesem Trip
beim Essen nicht heikel zu sein.
* Schwungvolle Rockmusik mit Dudel-
sack: "Epic Beersong" von Flannery *
(Schön.)
(Vieles
von dieser Schönheit der Natur
kommt für mich
jetzt am Fernsehen mehr rüber.)
(Damals konnte ich es
nicht so sehen.)
(Ganz ehrlich.)
* Lachen *
(Du hast auch immer
nur meinen Rücken angeschaut.)
Verdammt schön. Verdammt schön.
Siehst du die Schafe?
Ah ja.
So was mag ich.
Ich werde fast umgeweht.
Es ist schon sehr anders.
Hello.
- Hi.
(Aber hier sieht man es:
Noch keine 10 km gelatscht,
und es sieht schon nach Regen aus.)
Wo sind wir denn? Das ist nicht mehr
drauf. Nein, mach mich nicht krank!
Wir sind ... Nein. Wir sind
etwa hier und schauen zum Berg.
Sind wir schon
auf der zweiten Etappe?
Nein, aber kurz davor.
Wir sind jetzt auf diesem Stück.
Es ist so weit,
die ersten Regentropfen fallen.
Nein! Jetzt heisst es
Zelt aufstellen,
jetzt heisst es kochen ...
Nein.
Oh, mir fallen
die Sachen unten raus.
Was? Nein, das ist
der Lüftungsschacht, Schatz.
Ui ui ui!
(Peinlich!)
Das ist, damit es reinziehen kann.
- Das habe ich jetzt auch gemerkt.
Du kannst dein Portemonnaie
in diese Tasche tun.
Hör doch auf!
* Schwungvolle Rockmusik mit Dudel-
sack: "Epic Beersong" von Flannery *
Do you have water?
(Der Marathonläufer, nicht?)
- (Ja, genau.)
(In kurzen Hosen bei 4 °C.)
... make our camp here?
I think it's about 3 miles more
this way and you can camp.
There's a campsite?
- No, there's just no barbed wire.
If it's barbed off like that ...
(* Jonny ahmt den Jogger nach. *)
(Und wir beide:
"Yes, yes, good to know.")
(Und dann: "Du, was hat er gesagt?")
(Ich habe nichts verstanden,
dafür der Kameramann.)
(Ich habe wirklich
nichts verstanden.)
(Ah, genau, er sagte,
man dürfe nicht neben dem Bach.)
(Wir kapierten nichts
und campierten direkt daneben.)
(Singend)
Wir haben ein Zelt aufgestellt!
* Surren *
Das wird schwierig, so verklebt.
Ich weiss.
Es muss einfach gleichmässig sein.
(Genau, meine Haare!)
- (The barber.)
Musst du gleich von vorne reinhauen?
(Ich versuchte, die Haare mit
dem ganzen Gel drin zu schneiden.)
(Das ging natürlich gar nicht.)
(Jetzt musst du sie
mit Shampoo waschen.)
Und Dai Sun
arbeitet nicht mehr bei Ihnen?
Nein, Sie hat
die zweite Filiale übernommen.
Sie ist etwas weiter flussabwärts.
* Verspielte Musik *
Es ist nicht alles
ganz gleichmässig lang.
Was?
- Doch, doch.
Haben Sie noch andere ...
Das sieht geil aus.
- Ja, es sieht gut aus.
(Ich habe noch nie
Haare geschnitten.)
Noch andere Körperstellen?
- Alles schon gemacht.
(Aber es hat bis heute gehalten.)
(Ich trage diese Frisur immer noch.)
(Wegen Schottland.)
(Oh, ja.)
- (Jetzt beginnt die Misere.)
"Führen Sie die Pumpe
in die Brennstoffflasche ein
und befestigen Sie sie."
Mir ist das nicht geheuer.
- Das muss hier drauf.
Wir probieren es.
Das Einzige, was passieren kann,
ist, dass du Feuer fängst.
Wir haben beide
noch nie so ein Teil bedient.
Schon wieder aus.
Irgendwas stimmt nicht.
Sobald ich es offen habe ...
- So was macht mich rasend.
Bei so was habe ich keine Geduld.
- Schön warm.
Es schifft, ich habe kalte Finger.
Ich bin angepisst.
- Das ist echt blöd.
Das ist wirklich blöd gelaufen.
(Wir blenden immer. Drück Pause!)
(Das muss ich erklären:
Jonny, mein lieber Freund,
hat zum ersten Mal
eine Stirnlampe in Gebrauch.)
(Und nach ca. 1 Std. Kochen sagt er:
"Verdammt noch mal,
ich habe Nackenstarre!")
("Damit ich was sehe,
muss ich den Kopf so stark beugen.")
(Die Lampe kann man ja nach unten
abwinkeln, nach oben weniger,
aber er hatte sie verkehrt herum auf
und leuchtete in den Nachthimmel
oder in die Kameralinse hinein,
statt ins Essen.)
(Das ist köstlich.)
(Du lenkst ab,
weil du wütend wurdest.)
(Ja, ich komme auch gleich dran.)
... holen wir ihren ...
Kocher.
- ... Kocher hierher.
Was auch nervt:
Ich bin bis auf die Unterhose nass.
(Es war nicht unsere Schuld,
wir kämpften 1 Std. lang.)
(Dafür bekamen wir dann
den Brenner zum Kochen.)
(Es war nötig,
Burki war stinksauer.)
Ich glaube, er versucht,
seine Regenhose anzuziehen.
* Lachen *
Auch hier
ein verdammt blöder Lapsus!
Was ist denn?
Ich hatte eine Regenhose anprobiert,
die man an der Seite öffnen kann,
damit man die Schuhe
nicht ausziehen muss.
Ich musste sie jetzt aber ausziehen.
Haben sie dir
die falsche Hose gegeben?
Die haben doch nicht
etwas Falsches eingepackt.
Es ist eine Hose,
die man nicht öffnen kann.
Es ist mir ein Rätsel warum.
Hm, das macht mich wütend.
Fischer, lach nicht!
Burki, es tut mir leid, aber ich
finde es super. Ich finde es super.
Wir ...
- Nein, hey!
Komm, freuen wir uns,
zusammenzusitzen
und in dieser Pfütze
hier draussen zu kochen!
Es ist eine verdammte Pfütze!
Mach hier zu! Du hast immer noch
Luftlöcher. Da schifft es rein.
Da sieht man,
wie outdoortauglich ich bin.
Ah, ich liebe dich dafür, Burki.
Ja, ja.
- Ist gut.
(Voila, Safranrisotto!)
Isch güet, hm?
- Isch geil.
Es ist hüere güet.
Noch ein bisschen ...
Reicht das?
Es ist witzig: Wir haben uns
in den letzten 13 Jahren
in vielen Extremsituationen erlebt.
Aber so ein Fall, hier draussen
zu sitzen, es regnet, es windet,
man muss
einen Kocher in Gang bringen ...
Man hat Hunger und ist tropfnass.
- Das ist eine neue Situation.
(Mir ist das eingefahren,
dass wir zusammen
so eine Mini-Extremsituation
erlebten
in einer Art, wie wir es
noch nie erlebt haben.)
(V.a. standen wir am nächsten Morgen
auf und waren immer noch nass.)
(Es war ein Scheissstart.)
It was a fucking shit night.
(Wie redest du auch!)
(Ja, ich möchte mich entschuldigen.)
Mir geht es blendend.
Ich bin einfach eine Frohnatur.
Nein, nein,
es ist anders als zu Hause.
Es hat uns einen Hering rausgehoben,
dadurch hat es reingeregnet und
der Schlafsack ist nass geworden.
Das hält einen vom Schlafen ab.
Ich glaube, ich habe
keine Minute wirklich geschlafen.
Mir ist der Humor vergangen.
Ich habe eine gesunde Selbstironie,
ich kann lange über mich lachen,
aber mir ist der Humor
wirklich vergangen.
Jetzt geht es mir wieder besser,
ich hatte einen Tee.
Aber in der Nacht ...
Uh!
Ja, also ...
* Lachen *
* Der Regen prasselt aufs Zelt. *
(Das ist noch krass. Der Bach wurde
zum reissenden Fluss am Morgen.)
Was hast du mir noch übriggelassen?
- Wir konnten ja nicht kochen.
* Beschwingte Folk-Musik *
* "If I Ever Leave This World Alive"
von Flogging Molly *
(Ich weiss noch, das war um 9 Uhr
morgens, wir waren patschnass,
aber wir kamen
bei dieser Destillerie vorbei.)
(Unser Produzent organsierte
eine Whisky-Degustation
in einer Destillerie
morgens um 9 Uhr.)
(Grossartig!)
(Wirklich toll.
Glengoyne, oder wie hiess sie?)
(Genau.)
(Wir durften
unseren eigenen Whisky machen.)
* Beschwingte Folk-Musik *
Mein eigener.
So, dann habe ich meinen.
Es sieht auch noch schön aus.
(Der Whisky
hat uns noch manchmal gewärmt.)
Huhu!
- Thank you very much.
That was very quick.
Grossartig.
Destillerie - war gut.
10.30 Uhr, und wir hatten
noch kein Frühstück und nichts.
Einer der vermutlich
eher raren Momente
mit wärmenden Herbstsonnenstrahlen.
* Sanfte Musik: "Something
To Believe In" von King Creosote *
Wir haben zum ersten Mal
Sonne in Schottland,
das sind genau 3 cm der Zigarre.
Das heisst ... 10 Min. Sonne.
Not bad.
- Not bad.
Die Sonnenbrille kann man ablegen.
* Sanfte Musik: "Something
To Believe In" von King Creosote *
Good evening.
- Oh, it's the BBC.
Yes, sorry.
- Fuck off!
Fuck off!
If you feel like a drink or so,
let me know.
Ui, das ist schön!
Das ist schön!
Uah!
(Er hat uns doch
die nassen Schlafsäcke aufgehängt.)
(Und das nasse Zelt. Alles.)
Es war sensationell.
Ich bin einmal mehr
positiv überrascht
von der schottischen
Gastfreundschaft.
Die ganze Familie gehört dazu.
Er hat uns seine Frau
und seine Kinder vorgestellt.
Wir konnten heiss duschen,
das Zelt trocknen.
Er hat uns gleich gefragt,
ob wir nasse Sachen hätten.
Er hat unsere Schlafsäcke ...
- ... gleich vors Cheminee gelegt.
Er merkte gleich: "Hey,
wollt ihr nach dem engen Zelt
jetzt auch noch ein Bett teilen?
Nein. Ich hole eine Matratze."
Voll geil!
* Beschwingte Bluesmusik *
(Mit Ostschweizer Akzent) Wir gehen
jetzt da runter nach Wattwil
und essen im Bären etwas.
Oh nein!
(Oh, hier haben wir doch darum
gepinkelt, wer Tageschef wird.)
(Wer weiter pinkelt, ist Tageschef.)
Ich bin dafür, dass wir
noch etwas essen vor dem Anstieg.
Zieh dich warm an,
sonst erkältest du dich.
Es ist geil,
es ist ein super Gefühl.
Ich möchte beim Mittagessen
eine Zigarre rauchen
und den Erfolg geniessen.
Du bist ein toller Kerl.
Ich glaube,
ich bin ein fairer Führer.
Der erste!
Du musst den Rucksack nicht
anziehen, wir essen etwas. - Ach so?
Es ist noch nicht klar,
ob Tageschef sein
ein Vorteil oder ein Nachteil ist.
Es kann auch ein Nachteil sein, wenn
man Entscheidungen treffen muss.
(Ja, ich musste gehorchen.)
Mmh!
Au, ich hab mir
auf die Zunge gebissen. Sorry.
(Und jetzt Fischers Lachen.)
* Stöhnen *
Kennt ihr das?
Ah, Fu-C-K!
Hör auf zu lachen, Fischer!
(Hier sind wir
zum ersten Mal auf einen Berg.)
(Es hiess, es gehe auf einen Berg.)
(Hier hatte ich
langsam keine Lust mehr.)
* Blues-Rock:
"I'm On My Way" von The Proclaimers *
Wir steigen sicher auf den Gipfel.
Conic Hill, 358 m ü.M.
2'358 m ü.M.
Das Atmen macht schon Mühe.
(Wir konnten die Rucksäcke ablegen,
um hochzulaufen. Gott sei Dank.)
(Es war geil, der Wind blies,
es regnete. Ich mag das.)
Oh, ist das geil.
Yeah!
- Wow!
* Lachen *
Man kann sich fast
in den Wind legen.
Wunderschöne Aussicht, Loch Lomond.
Bis jetzt habe ich mich
darüber aufgeregt,
dass die Kameracrew ihre Rucksäcke
und das Zelt in den Bus legen kann
und wir alles mitschleppen müssen.
Jetzt sind unsere Rucksäcke unten
und die mussten alles schleppen.
* Hämisches Lachen *
Wo ist Burkart? Der versteckt sich
wieder irgendwo in den Highlands.
Komme gleich.
Nein! Hey, verschwinde!
Hör auf!
- Du Sau.
Ich hatte gestern wohl zu viel
Knoblauchsauce an den Crevetten.
* Blues-Rock:
"I'm On My Way" von The Proclaimers *
(Wie hiess das Kaff?)
(Also, dieses Kaff
bestand aus einem Hotel.)
(The Oak Tree.)
- (Keine Ahnung, wie das hiess.)
(Ein trauriges Kämmerchen
hatten wir hier.)
(Aber eine warme Dusche.)
Verdammt heiss. Das ist das Geilste
nach einem solchen Tag.
Eine heisse Dusche und dann einen
Kaffee oder etwas trinken gehen -
das ist verdammt geil.
Dann lass ich dich jetzt
in intimity.
Super, danke.
* Gemütliche Musik:
"Dirty Old Town" von The Pogues *
* Baulärm *
(Laut) Ein neuer Tag.
Heute ist der Start
in die Highlands.
Natur pur.
- Wir freuen uns.
Deswegen sind wir hergereist,
dieses Natürliche,
wir sind ganz natürlich unterwegs.
Schön!
Das hat man in der Schweiz nicht.
Nirgends. Das ist Natur pur.
* Gemütliche Musik:
"Dirty Old Town" von The Pogues *
Wir sind zackig unterwegs. Das ist
nicht Wandern, sondern Marschieren.
Wir haben die letzte Stunde
nicht geredet,
weil wir zackig unterwegs sind.
Ich hoffe, dass wir bis jetzt ...
Was waren das?
- 5 km?
Das würde ich auch sagen.
Es sind also noch ...
13 km.
- 13-14 km
Die Sonne kommt raus!
Ganz gute Bilder.
Das ist die längste Etappe, nicht?
Ich hoffe,
dass wir keine längere haben.
Das reicht eigentlich schon.
(Wenn mich nicht alles täuscht, ist
das der längste See Schottlands.)
(Und wir sind zwei oder drei Tage
dem See entlang gelaufen.)
* Gemütliche Musik:
"Dirty Old Town" von The Pogues *
(Hier ging es wieder
um den Tageschef, nicht?)
Hör auf! Abstand, Abstand, bitte!
Ein, zwei.
- Zwei!
Okay.
Drei.
Das ist nicht gut für die Schulter.
- Ja, stimmt.
Nein! Zwei.
Sechs. Fünf oder Sechs.
- Fünf. Fünf.
Das ist der Letzte.
Zwei.
Ah!
So, jetzt wird wieder klar angesagt:
Wir gehen los, wir machen noch 4 km
und essen dann,
obwohl es schon 12 Uhr ist.
Ich hätte zwar Hunger.
- Das spielt keine Rolle.
Jetzt kann er mich quälen.
- Absolut.
Und die verdammte Sänfte,
blödes Team.
Ich will eine Sänfte.
Das habe ich gestern schon gesagt.
Eine Sänfte - das könnt ihr doch ...
Damit ich so ...
Du meinst, wir tragen dich
durch die Landschaft?
Ich habe etwas abgenommen.
(Ah, du mit deiner ...)
- (Sänfte.)
(Das ist ein Wort, das ich
bis zu diesem Moment nicht kannte.)
Mit Steinen geht es nicht gut, aber
Rucksack-Schiferen, das wäre was.
Wenn du es mit deinem machst, ja.
Jetzt will Monsieur Tageschef
auf seinem Stuhl dort hinten,
dass man ihn trägt.
Er wird gerade bedient,
der Tageschef auf seinem Stuhl.
* Punk-Rock:
"Nellie The Elephant" von Toy Dolls *
Nein, nein, Streit gibt es sicher
keinen wegen des Tageschefs.
Ich frage ihn ab und zu schon,
ob es okay sei.
Und das Wasser tragen wir beide,
das ist klar.
Oh!
Schwierige Situationen
übernehme ich manchmal einfach so.
Ja, ja.
Wenn wir etwas Schwieriges
klären müssen, bin ich oft ...
Wenn es darum geht,
dass die Harmonie gebrochen wird,
habe ich oft nicht die Eier dazu,
die Faust auf den Tisch zu hauen.
Das macht er.
Und manchmal, aber nicht immer,
hast du genug davon.
Ja, denn dann
bin ich immer das Arschloch:
"Das sind zwar zwei lustige Komiker,
aber der Blonde ist ja mühsam!"
Wobei, oft ist es so,
dass es dich mehr stresst als mich.
Das ist dann eine blöde, kleine
Differenz bei der Empfindung,
die ihn dann aber fast dazu zwingt,
die Initiative zu ergreifen.
Aber ja, wir haben
schon einige Situationen erlebt.
Hier bis jetzt noch nicht.
- Nein, hier nicht.
Ich freue mich jetzt riesig
auf ein wärmendes Feuer.
Du kannst ihn mir geben.
- Jetzt musst du das Wasser nehmen.
Danke.
* Sanfte Flötenmusik *
Es kann nicht mehr weit sein.
Durch den Wald abkürzen,
mag ich immer.
Bis jetzt lief es nicht schlecht.
Das sieht etwas spooky aus.
- Mega spooky.
(Oh, das war schlimm.
Das war ein Scheisshütte.)
Das ist ja der Hammer!
- Wo ist der Eingang?
Ah, dort oben.
- Das ist der Hammer.
Brennnesseln.
Es sieht aber schon
etwas schlimm aus.
Mal schauen, wie es innen aussieht.
- Ja, ja.
Rowchoish Bothy.
* Lachen *
Das ist doch geil.
Das ist doch de luxe, nicht?
Ich finde, es ist der Hammer.
- Ich bin mega froh.
Es ist wirklich der Hammer.
Logisch, es ist fast immer
unbewohnt, es ist dreckig,
aber das gehört auch
zu dieser Reise.
Absolut. Ich bin froh.
Der heutige Tag war etwas lang.
Ich bin etwas am Arsch.
Ich brauche Schokolade.
Willst du? Ich habe hier.
- Das wäre mega lieb.
Ich muss echt ...
- Von zu Hause.
Ich habe am Schluss ... Für hierher
mussten wir alles packen ...
* Schlag *
Jetzt ist die Tür endlich mal zu.
... für diese zwei Tage,
Essen und alles.
Und gegen Ende
wurde es wirklich anstrengend.
Ich habe auch eine Blase
am rechten Fuss. Es war anstrengend.
Ist es Benzin?
Diesel, aber ja ...
(Schön, mit der Zigarre im Mund
mit dem Feuer rumspielen!)
(Ja, aber zack, und es ging.)
(Liebe Kinder,
macht das nicht zu Hause!)
Zumachen.
Und anzünden.
Nehmen wir die Sachen weg.
Achtung, Feuer... Wie heisst das?
Voll easy.
- Das wärmt auch gleich.
Und ich kann die Zigarre
noch mal anzünden.
Die Nasenspitze wärmen.
(Das ganze Gestell brennt.)
- (Der ganze Tisch brennt.)
Warte mal,
wie haben wir das gemacht?
Voila!
Muss man noch mal pumpen?
Ja, es muss Druck
auf der Flasche sein.
Kann ich ihn draufstellen?
- Ja!
Ja, das ist doch easy.
Das ganze Zeug ist doch easy.
Es gibt etwas Warmes zu essen.
Mmh!
Ganz guten Appetit!
(Das war einer der glückseligsten
Momente dieser Reise.)
Ich sage nichts mehr.
* Sanfte Musik *
Das kann aber rein, das ist Karton.
Hier kam Lagerstimmung auf.
- Darauf hatte ich mich gefreut.
Waldbrandgefahr
besteht hier wohl nicht gross.
Ich glaube, das gab es
in Schottland noch nie.
Verdammt schön!
* Sanfte Musik *
* Drollige Musik *
(Jesses, schau dir das an! Nein!)
(So eine traurige ... Ah!)
Kalt ist es!
- Und jetzt v.a. aufstehen.
Komm jetzt, aufstehen!
Du mit deinen
sexy langen Unterhosen!
Hör auf!
Ich gehe
und mache Spiegeleier und Speck.
Ich hätte lieber ein Continental.
Vielleicht etwas Lachs,
gerne etwas Lachs?
Super, und ein Schlückchen Prosecco.
Ja, den hole ich gleich im Keller.
Ah!
* "King Of The Road"
von The Proclaimers *
Mega schön.
Tag ...
- Kleine Augen.
Ja, ja, kleine Augen.
In dieser Waldhütte geschlafen ...
Tag wie viel haben wir? Fünf?
Für dich sechs, für mich fünf.
Tag fünf -
wir sind eigentlich noch recht fit.
Ich glaube, Fischer
drückt an einer Stelle der Schuh.
Meine Waden brennen etwas,
aber sonst sind wir fit,
nicht wahr, Fischer?
Endlich einmal
ein richtiger Wasserfall.
Hallo!
Hallo, ich heisse Jonny!
(Mike, unser Glarner Auswanderer.
Ich fasse es nicht.)
(Der hat doch
einen ganzen See gepachtet.)
Fängt man hier überhaupt etwas?
Mir stinkt es, wenn ich stundenlang
an einem See sitze und nichts fange.
Die Chancen stehen heute
relativ gut, dass wir etwas fangen.
(Darauf hatte ich mich gefreut.)
- (Fischen ist nicht so mein Ding.)
(Ich konnte nicht mehr warten.)
(Kameramann) Moment, der Ton ist
nur auf dem Mischer. Autofahrt!
Klappe!
Ja, halt doch selbst die Klappe!
Ja, ein konstruktiver Kommentar
von Herrn Fischer!
Dann gehen wir los!
* Sanfte, majestätische Musik *
(Was hat Mike schon alles gemacht?)
(Alles Mögliche, Berufsmilitär,
Maurer - das weiss ich noch.)
(Aquakultur studiert. Und jetzt
Hechtfischen mit Touristen.)
(Anker los und dann mit acht Ruten,
auf jeder Seite vier.)
(Wir haben nicht daran geglaubt.
Aber schau mal!)
Mein Gott!
- Nein, er ist draussen.
Warte, jetzt geht dieser Fisch ab.
Ich fasse es nicht!
Kann ich ihn so lassen?
Nur warten! Das ist
wahrscheinlich ein grosser Fisch.
Immer auf Spannung gehen!
Merkt er noch nicht,
dass er dran ist? - Nein.
Hast du gesehen,
wie er gerissen hat?
Wenn er das erste Mal hochkommt,
siehst du ihn.
Schön auf dieser Seite behalten!
Hier behalten, hier behalten!
- Wie gross ist das Viech?
Einiges über 1 m.
Hier behalten, hier behalten!
Zum Zeugs raushalten!
Hier behalten! Schön.
Kontrollieren, kontrollieren!
Kontrollieren!
Jetzt geht er ab wie die Sau.
Scheisse,
schau, wie gross das Vieh ist!
Wow, Scheisse!
Easy, easy, easy!
Ganz easy nehmen!
Raufnehmen! Jawohl. Herannehmen!
Cool, der ist im Netz.
Scheisse! Wow, Scheisse!
Schau dir das an!
Schau dir das an.
Wow, Scheisse!
Oh, krass!
Schau dir das an!
Was wiegt der?
Weit über 20 Pfund,
weit über 20 Pfund.
Das ich das einmal erleben darf,
hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Unglaublich!
20 Pfund.
(Speziell ist ja, dass sie den Fisch
nicht töten, sondern zurückwerfen.)
Ich kapiere nicht, warum er
nicht zappelt wie verrückt.
Warum hat keine Panik?
Weil ich ihn ganz ruhig behandle.
So macht es ihm nichts aus.
Der Fisch ist nicht verletzt,
der Haken macht ihm nichts.
Genau so, Jungs.
- Man spürt ja den Puls.
Aber etwas eklig ist er schon.
Das ist der Hammer.
Hey, danke, Mike!
Das ist der Wahnsinn.
Man hört, wie er pulsiert.
Dieser arme Kerl.
Ich kapiere nicht,
dass er so ruhig ist.
Das ändert sich,
wenn ihr ihn wieder zurückwerft.
24 Pfund.
1,10 m.
Wahnsinn!
- Ein schottischer Hecht.
Jetzt unterstützt man ihn
hier ganz leicht.
Wow!
Wahnsinn!
Vielen Dank.
Der Haken kommt extrem
leicht heraus, kaum Blut.
Ich fand es eindrücklich,
ihn zu streicheln. Wie ein Haustier.
Und dann lässt man sie
sanft wieder hinein.
Es ist sicher kein Vergnügen
für den Fisch,
aber das Trauma
hat er bald verarbeitet.
Ich denke auch. Es war geil.
Bombastisch!
- Sehr, sehr geil!
Jetzt noch
das Blut von den Händen waschen.
* Dynamische Musik *
(Wir übernachteten
in diesem alten Haus.)
(Eine bekannte, schottische Legende
wohnte doch dort.)
(Der Wilhelm Tell von Schottland.)
- (Ich weiss nicht, wie er hiess.)
(Roy Bob, Bob Roy, Rob Boy ...)
Schau dir das an!
Wenn du hier in der Badewanne
liegst, schau dir diese Aussicht an!
Ja, jetzt ist es blöd,
weil es spiegelt.
Hier siehst du den Berg, den See -
ein Traum!
So geil!
Jetzt noch einen Kaffee
oder einen Tee - grossartig.
Oh, ist das schön.
(Und zum ersten Mal
getrennte Betten, Manu.)
(Das hat gut getan.)
Mike, was erwartet uns hier?
Jetzt darfst du es uns sagen.
Als Nächstes gehen wir
auf die Leddard Farm.
Dort werden wir zuerst
Tontauben schiessen.
Geil!
Das macht Fischer Freude!
(Ein stranger Bauernhof
mit strangen Menschen.)
(Absolut.)
Es ist mir fast etwas peinlich.
Ich habe mich so gefreut.
Ich dachte noch:
Was ist, wenn es dann nicht geht?
Das wäre schade. Aber irgendwie
hat es sehr gut geklappt.
Pull!
Yeah! Good lad, good lad!
I love it, I love it!
Pull!
Smoking!
That's a beautiful shot.
Yeah, brilliant! You got it.
So geil!
Es ist so etwas Schönes.
Es riecht.
# Oh!
* Punk-Rock:
"Nellie The Elephant" von Toy Dolls *
Tonight we're gonna be
real scottish guys.
It's only the kilt we're missing.
- Absolutely.
Wir haben die schottische Tracht
bekommen: den Kilt.
Wir haben uns den halben Tag
auf den Kilt gefreut.
Wir haben jetzt auch etwas bekommen.
Aber beim Anfassen,
haben wir gemerkt,
dass es ein normales Badetuch ist.
Das passt auf diese Farm.
Ein riesen Tamtam war das.
Unser Traum war doch,
einmal einen Kilt zu tragen.
Sie sagten, dass wir
sicher nicht den Mut hätten,
die Unterhosen auszuziehen.
Und jetzt bekommen wir ein Badetuch.
Sie sagten, es kämen
noch zehn Leute im richtigen Kilt.
Und wir müssen im Badetuch
mit den Leuten feiern.
Nein, also in einem Badetuch!
Sie haben
auch noch einen Hut organisiert.
Das ist aber eine billige Perücke.
Ich würde mich damit
an der Fasnacht schämen.
(Hier war Herr Fischer
richtig wütend.)
(Ich war enttäuscht.)
Es ist ein neues Gefühl, unter dem
Badetuch die Unterhosen auszuziehen.
Ich bin ganz nervös.
Ich habe schon lange mal gesagt,
dass ich einmal
einen Kilt anziehen möchte.
Aber kein Badetuch!
Ich finde, der Hut
steht dir besonders gut.
Du musst aber die Hose ausziehen.
(Ich war so beschäftigt
mit Fluchen und Umziehen,
dass ich dich nie angeschaut habe.)
Sehe ich auch so scheisse aus?
Du hast richtig rote Haare.
Du solltest dich mal ...
Jetzt habe ich
trotzdem noch etwas Freude.
(Sie sagten dann, sie hätten extra
einen Abend für uns organisiert.)
(Wir wussten nichts.)
(Wir standen vor der Tür und
mussten tun, was uns gesagt wurde.)
(Wir wussten nichts.)
- (Das war ein totaler Blindflug.)
(Wir liefen dann einer gefüllten
Leber ... Oder was war es?)
(... einem Schafsmagen hinterher.)
(Wir bekamen keine Anweisung,
einfach nur hinterherlaufen.)
Fair fa' your honest, sonsie face,
great chieftain o' the pudding-race.
Aboon them a' yet tak your place,
painch, tripe, or thairm:
Weel are ye wordy o'a grace
as lang's my arm.
The groaning trencher
there ye fill,
your hurdies like a distant hill,
your pin was help to mend a mill
in time o'need.
Cut you up wi' ready sleight, yeah!
Ye Pow'rs,
wha mak mankind your care,
and dish them out
their bill o' fare.
Well done, boys.
(Hauptsache mitschreien!)
- (Hauptsache mitmachen!)
(Und viel zu viel Essen
haben sie aufgetischt.)
(Viel zu viel!)
Wunderschön war,
wie sich das gewendet hat
mit dem Einlaufen in den Esssaal.
Wir wussten nicht, worauf wir uns
einlassen, mit dem Dudelsack voraus.
Er hat neben uns
sein Theater durchgezogen.
Unsere Stimmung hat sich gewendet.
Wir haben gemerkt, dass wir
den Abend fliessen lassen können
und er v.a. interessant wird.
* Fröhliche Musik *
Heute war ein Wahnsinnstag,
ein Up-and-Down-Tag.
Wir haben heute Abend gedacht,
dass wir uns mit diesem Kostüm
total lächerlich machen würden.
Aber es hat alles gepasst.
Es war zwar alles etwas aufgesetzt,
aber es hat gepasst.
Wir haben hier hineingepasst.
Es hat mir sehr gefallen.
* Fröhliche, schottische Musik *
(Das war ein langes Weekend
bei den kurligen Schotten.)
(Ja, und wir haben uns ja dann
von Mike verabschiedet,
und sind zurück auf den Weg.)
(Wir waren dann auch froh,
wieder weiterwandern zu können.)
(Das weiss ich noch.)
* "I'm Gonna Be"
von Sleeping at Last *
* Sanfte, getragene Musik
und Gesang *
... 6 m, gespreizte Beine
und dann dort aufschlagen.
Wasser!
Wenn wir jetzt mit dem Zeug
hinuntergefallen wären.
Dann hättet ihr Freude, so wie bei
meiner Thermosflasche auf dem See!
* "I'm Gonna Be"
von Sleeping at Last *
Es ist wieder einmal mehr typisch.
Man denkt, man sei bald am Ziel.
Einmal mehr:
Der letzte Kilometer ...
... hört und hört und hört
nicht auf.
Dort ist Ardlui.
Dort ist ein Ballon,
den man hochziehen muss.
So sieht der Fährmann
auf der anderen Seeseite,
dass man abgeholt werden will.
* Jonny ahmt
den Fahnenmarsch nach. *
* Rasante, schottische Musik *
Jetzt bin ich auch glücklich.
(Ardlui, genau. Ah!)
(Dort im Hotel habe ich mich
wohlgefühlt. Das war schön.)
(Es war auch speziell. Am
nächsten Tag hattest du Geburtstag.)
(Ach, ja, stimmt!)
Erste Handwäsche.
Ich musste waschen und ich glaube,
auch für die Körperhygiene
ist es wieder einmal gut,
in ein Schaumbad zu liegen.
Ich bin happy, wieder einmal
in einem Hotel zu sein,
mit Badewanne oder Dusche.
Ich freue mich.
Puh, das stinkt!
Schau dir das Wasser an!
That feels good.
Ich weiss nicht,
wie lange man das machen muss.
(Ja, und du wusstest ja nicht, dass
ich im Hotel organisieren musste.)
(Ich habe Manu überrascht,
und zwar mit seiner Frau.)
(Ich habe deine Frau angerufen,
das wusstest du nicht.)
(Ich musste wissen,
wann ihr Flugzeug ankommt
und welche Busse und Züge fahren.)
(Wir wollten dich
zum Geburtstag überraschen.)
Hoi, Mischi!
Er ahnt überhaupt nichts.
(Oh, Halloween!)
- (Halloweenparty!)
(Wir gingen in dieses Loch.)
(Hier findet jedes Jahr eine
legendäre Halloweenparty statt.)
(Wir waren genau dann dort,
das war krass.)
* Gespenstisches Lachen *
Für den Schotten ist Halloween
wie für den Luzerner die Fasnacht.
Halloween hat hier
einen anderen Stellenwert.
Bei uns ist Halloween
erst im Kommen.
Ich bin sehr gespannt.
Mal schauen, ob wir hier in meinen
Geburtstag feiern oder früher gehen.
* Rasante, schottische Musik *
* Sanfte Klänge *
Ich durfte einen
unvergesslichen Geburtstag feiern.
So schnell gibt es das nicht wieder.
Ich werde es aber auch im Kreis
der Familie wieder geniessen.
* Gemächliche Musik: "Miserable
Strangers" von King Creosote *
# It's my birthday,
It's my birthday!
See you next time. Thanks.
- See you next time.
* "Miserable Strangers"
von King Creosote *
Es ist auch geil,
wenn wir sagen können,
dass nur an deinem Geburtstag
schönes Wetter war.
Dieses Wetter ist wirklich
ein Geburtstagsgeschenk.
(Mit diesem Zug kam deine Frau,
und du wusstest es nicht.)
(Sie sass da drin.)
- (Krass.)
(Wir liefen über das Gleis
und sie sass drin.)
Es ist eigentlich
immer noch wie im Engadin.
Ich fühle mich langsam wohler.
Es ist etwas hügeliger, bergiger,
steiniger. Das freut mich.
Und dass ich das
an meinem Geburtstag,
an einem so wunderschönen Tag er-
leben darf - I really appreciate it.
Da sind sie: meine Highlands.
(Dieses Mäuerchen -
das war so schön.)
(Du auf dem Mäuerchen
und ich auf dem Weg.)
(Das war wirklich schön.)
(Ich wusste, noch 1 Std. wandern
und dann kommt die Überraschung.)
(Und du wusstest nichts davon.)
(Oh, hier in diesem Scheisshotel.
Oh, shit!)
(Und es ist wieder schattig.)
(Hier sieht man, ich musste schauen:
Wo ist Michele, wo sind die Kameras,
wie machen wir es?)
Was macht ihr eigentlich?
Also, Herr Burkart ...
- What the hell is going on?
# Happy birthday to you.
Nein, nein, nein! Spinnt ihr?
Scheisse!
Hoi!
Ich gratuliere dir
ganz herzlich zum Geburtstag.
Hoi!
- Spinnt ihr eigentlich?
Du hast nichts gemerkt, oder?
- Nein!
Komm her! Ein Drückerchen.
Hey, nein, das ist jetzt gerade
ziemlich surreal.
Shit!
Was machst du
hier in diesen Crianlarich?
Ich bin für dich gekommen.
Das ist auf Jonnys Mist gewachsen.
Ich bin
mit dieser Situation überfordert.
Ich bin Röbi Koller
und fange das Ganze etwas auf.
So geht es weiter:
Wir gehen zurück ins Studio.
Nein, wie kommst du hierher?
- So schön.
Meine Frau steht hier!
* Fröhliche, schottische Musik *
219 haben sie gesagt.
Ich komme.
- Es ist 6 Uhr.
Ich sage noch Tschüss.
Sie geht zum Flughafen.
Hast du fertig gepackt?
- Ja.
Ist es noch etwas früh?
Ich liebe Kameralicht frühmorgens.
Es war mega cool.
Passt auf!
Du bist zweieinhalb Tage unterwegs
für die 12 Std.
Danke, dass du mitgemacht hast.
Gutes Durchhalten.
- Vielen Dank.
Macht es gut
und saugt noch alles auf!
Behaltet die Nerven!
Das kommt ganz auf die Crew an.
Also, macht es gut.
Tschüss, viel Spass!
Gute Reise!
Jö!
- Gute Nacht.
Nein, in 20 Min.
treffen wir uns draussen.
(Hier geht es los mit Stirnlampen,
und arschkalt am Morgen früh.)
Crianlarich. Scotrail.
Hierher komme ich
nicht unbedingt zurück.
Ja, ich habe es auch gesehen.
# Im Wald, im schöne grüene Wald
han ich äs Plätzli, womer gfallt.
Von wem ist das?
# Ich ligge da im weiche Moos ...
Das habe ich
im Kindergarten gelernt.
So, Bürkeli!
Ist hier "half"?
Jetzt haben wir die Hälfte.
- Half of the way.
Kannst du hier unser
Zielschnäppschen heraussuchen?
Das Problem ist,
wir haben die Hälfte des Weges ...
... und die Hälfte des Fläschchens.
... und schon
zwei Drittel der Zeit gebraucht.
Jetzt müssen wir Gas geben.
Es ist 7.15 Uhr und wir haben
noch kein Frühstück gehabt.
Oh, so schön!
Ab jetzt gibt es nichts mehr.
Super, einmal mehr
auf nüchternen Magen!
7.15 Uhr. Das haben wir schon
zum zweiten Mal zum Frühstück.
Hu!
Es wärmt. Da muss ich gleich
alles ausziehen.
* "I'm Gonna Be (500 Miles)"
von The Proclaimers *
(Wir waren sehr schnell unterwegs.)
(Kameramann) Ihr könnt weitergehen.
(Ja, ja,
immer auf die Kamera warten!)
Ihr könnt weitergehen.
* "I'm Gonna Be (500 Miles)"
von The Proclaimers *
* Quietschen *
Es muss quietschen.
(Ein uralter Friedhof.)
- (Schöne Grabsteine.)
(Das war ein mystischer Ort.)
(Immer wieder
fand ich in Schottland,
dass es eine gewisse Mystik hat.
So auch hier.)
Dort ist eine Kameracrew.
Überall hat es schöne Natur
und dann solches Zeugs dort oben.
(Oh, dieser traurige Campingplatz.
Endlich Frühstück!)
(Wie liefen etwa 3 Std.)
Hier geht es dann bergauf -
Scheisse!
Drei, vier, fünf ...
- Geil!
... sechs, sieben, acht, neun, zehn.
Sind wir heute ... äh ...
... im Bridge of ...
Bitch of Orchy.
- Bitch of Orchy.
Dort sind wir heute.
Schön - Bitch of Orchy.
Und das Loch Trulla.
Das ist so geil.
Ich freue mich sehr,
dass ich so fit bin.
Klar, es kann noch die eine
oder andere Steigung kommen.
Es ist einfach schön,
die Zeit zum Wandern zu haben.
Ich merke,
dass mir das sehr gut tut.
V.a. dass ...
Das haben wir vorhin besprochen.
Der Druck, den man daheim hat ...
Jede Stunde schaut man doch nach,
ob man eine E-Mail bekommen hat.
Das ist hier anders.
Hier schaut man nicht nach und
Facebook und alles ist weit weg.
Das tut gut.
- Ja. Wirklich.
(Hier waren wir in der Hälfte.)
(Ich merkte,
wie mein Geist runterfuhr,
und zwar erst nach ca. zehn Tagen.)
(Man merkt es uns auch an.)
(Wir sind mega ruhig,
wir hören einander zu.)
(Man ist sehr bei sich selbst.)
(Das war super.)
* Sanfte Musik *
(Aber deswegen
gingen wir ja auch dorthin.)
(Um unsere Freundschaft zu pflegen.)
(Aber um Freundschaft zu pflegen,
sind Wettkämpfe nicht förderlich.)
(Die Sache mit dem Tageschef.)
Der Tageschef hat quasi die Voll-
macht über gewisse Entscheidungen:
wo man schläft, wann man
eine Essenspause macht ...
... oder übernachtet.
Nach einer Woche haben wir ent-
schieden, dass wir das durchziehen.
Man spürt die Begeisterung
bei meinem heissgeliebten,
38-jährigen Freund.
Die Begeisterung
war von Anfang an brodelnd.
Komm, wir gehen weiter
und überlegen!
(Haben wir hier nicht
den Tageschef ...)
(... sein lassen.)
(Ich weiss nicht mehr.)
(Wir beschlossen, den Tageschef
zu begraben, hörten auf damit.)
(Ja, es brachte nichts.
Es gab zu wenig her.)
(Nein, es gab nur Diskussionen
und Auseinandersetzungen.)
Wir lassen
das Sideprojekt Tageschef sterben.
Das Chefsein, das Militärische,
das Hierarchische ...
In unserer Zusammenarbeit
hat das keinen Platz.
Auch wir als Personen ... Ich hatte
im Militär grosse Mühe damit.
Manu auch. Das war auch eine
Auseinanderersetzung als Lehrer.
Ich sage nicht gerne: "So und so
geht es." Das kann ich nicht.
Ich weiss, dass das
den anderen nicht passt.
Wir sind eher mehr
die Spürst-du-mich-Fraktion,
die alles ausdiskutiert,
bis es für alle stimmt.
Ja, definitiv.
Geht es dir auch so?
Das konnte man schon
in vielen Interviews lesen,
auch Leute, die um mich herum sind,
wissen: Ich bin ein Harmonie-Freak.
D.h. nicht, dass ich mich
vor allen Spannungen drücke.
Denen stelle ich mich schon,
aber nicht gerne.
Und es ist mir auch klar ...
# Schubabaluba bow.
Tageschef!
* Punkmusik:
"Hey Ho, Let's Go" von Ramones *
Immer muss ich warten.
Er hat langsam Entzugserscheinungen
nach der Zivilisation.
Ich bin dafür, dass man
den Tageschef wieder einführt.
Das ist einfach kein ...
Er kann kein Tempo annehmen.
Das ist richtig Service public,
dafür bezahlen die Leute.
Wir probieren aus, wie Nacktwandern
im hohen Norden sich anfühlt.
Nacktwandern hat mich
schon immer interessiert.
2. November, alles schneidet ein
und es ist arschkalt - 4 °C.
Wie viel Grad?
- 4 °C oder so ähnlich.
Wenn ich auf mein Thermometer hin-
unterschaue, haben wir unter Null.
Komm, Burki!
- Ja, ja, komm!
(Es heisst ja immer,
Burki hat eine doofe Idee
und Fischer muss mitmachen.
Hier war es umgekehrt.)
(Hier musste Burki mitmachen.)
* Punkmusik:
"Hey Ho, Let's Go" von Ramones *
Sieht das geil aus!
* Sanfte Musik: "An Roghain Dain
Do Eimhir XXII" von Julie Fowlis *
Schon über die Strasse
riecht es nach schottischem Hotel.
Das ist mir wieder ein Castle!
Hui, jetzt spüre ich meine Beine.
- Ich auch.
Der rechte Fuss ...
Du, das ist ein Viersternehotel.
Hör auf!
Ein Viersternehotel,
schottisches Viersternehotel.
Weit war es.
Das sagt mir: 25,5 km - heute.
* Der Fernseher läuft. *
(Totale Begeisterung.)
(Ich lag halbkrank im Bett
und merkte,
dass Burkart am nächsten Tag im
Regen Braveheart spielen wollte.)
* Lachen *
Ich habe ein kleines Döschen
blaue Gesichtsfarbe mitgenommen.
Ich dachte, es wäre cool, auf
unserer Reise das nachzustellen.
Er ist mein Heer.
* Ruhige Gitarrenklänge *
Goodbye Brigde of Orchy.
Leider, leider,
es war ein Hammer-Hotel.
Burkart-Fischer -
das erste Mal leicht angeschlagen.
Leicht angeschlagen.
Das rote Männchen neben mir
hat leichtes Fieber,
einen blöden Kopf
und mir knackt die linke Hüfte.
Ich wurde 38, das hat sich
sofort niedergeschlagen.
Alles ist anders.
Wir schaffen das,
aber die letzten drei, vier Tage
müssen wir noch etwas kämpfen.
Jetzt müssen wir
etwas sorgfältiger sein.
Die letzten zwei Tage
sind wir gerannt.
Und das bergerprobte Team
ist total begeistert,
wie wir trainiert und schnell sind.
Wir müssen hier hinauf.
Jetzt haben wir sie beeindruckt.
Von jetzt an können wir normal sein
und gemütlich hier hinaufgehen.
(Gemütlich -
das haben wir uns oft gesagt,
und wir sind jedes Mal
doch wieder gerannt.)
(Hier habe ich gelitten.)
* Sanfte Musik *
* "I'm Gonna Be" von George MacKay,
Antonia Thomas, Peter Mullan *
Ich muss heute etwas sorgfältiger
sein. Ich bin etwas angeschlagen.
Das ist der einzige Hügel.
Ich muss schauen, dass ich
nicht schon am Anschlag bin.
Ich habe heute Nacht
extrem geschwitzt.
Ich glaube,
Fieber habe ich nicht mehr.
Schluckweh habe ich noch.
* Sanfte Musik *
(Hier haben wir doch mit einem
Förster oder Jäger abgemacht.)
(Genau, das war hier.)
Von einem Jäger
hat man ein klares Bild.
Die reden wenig.
Sie sind still, damit sie
die Rehe nicht aufscheuchen.
(Flüstert) Ganz leise.
- (Flüstert) Ganz leise.
Ja, das ist er.
- Schau dir dieses Gefährt an!
Nice to meet you!
- Callum.
(Das Amphibienfahrzeug war cool.)
... your management in this area?
How big is this area?
35'000 ha.
Sorry?
What's our plan?
Would you like to take
a ride in this?
That would be great.
(35'000 ha,
das ist grösser als der Kanton Zug.)
(Heftig. Das Moor!)
* Schwungvolle Musik:
"The Passenger" von Iggy Pop *
Ich hätte vorher
besser noch gepinkelt.
Jetzt ist es zu spät.
Wir können mit der Fahrt
nicht viele Kilometer aufholen.
Aber es ist cool. Wir sind irgendwo,
wo nie ein Mensch hinkommt.
Da kommt die Crew
durch den Nebel hinauf.
Sie müssen durch den Morast laufen.
Das ist anstrengend.
The bridge is missing here,
so we're just gonna cross
slightly higher up.
(Genau, ich musste absteigen,
weil die Brücke kaputt war
oder weggespült wurde.)
(Die Brücke war weg.)
Thank you very, very much.
- Nice to meet you.
Princes of Scotland!
Bye!
Kopfsteinpflaster.
- Ja, genau.
* Majestätische Musik *
Traumhaft hier oben - diese Ruhe.
* Erhabene Musik *
(Das war traumhaft. Wow!)
- (Ja, wirklich.)
(Hier war ich richtig geflasht
von der Schönheit.)
(Hier hast du aus der Zigarrenhülle
eine Flöte gebastelt.)
(Das ging eher in die Hose.)
* Schiefe Töne *
* Sanfte, friedvolle Musik *
(Ein langer Tag.)
- (Aber eine coole Unterkunft.)
(Sehr einfach und etwas schmuddelig,
aber trotzdem stilvoll.)
(Sehr schottisch.)
- (Total schön.)
Fein, nicht?
Heute Morgen können wir von hier ...
... oben durch,
zuerst der Strasse nach.
Eine sehr schöne Strecke -
man läuft direkt neben der Autobahn.
(Oh, hier haben wir
diesen Typen getroffen!)
(Oh, Steve!)
It's quite cold. You slept in here?
- Yeah.
Wow. It wasn't too cold?
(Er ist ein Vagabund.)
The last one lasted ten years,
so it's twelve years in these.
(Er lebt hier drin und fährt
einfach auf der Insel rum.)
(Ja, irgendwie so.)
I've spent most of my life
meeting people.
Bye!
- Bye! - Bye!
Mega interessant.
- Cool!
Huh, aber hard to understand.
- Ja, schwierig zu verstehen.
* Erhabene Musik *
(The Devil's Staircase - schön,
hier wurde es etwas alpin, bergig.)
(Das gefiel mir.)
- (Ja, aber es war steil.)
(Du bist da hochgerannt.)
Wir befinden uns
auf der Devil's Staircase,
eine steile, höllisch
schweisstreibende Passage
auf eine Passhöhe hinauf.
Da wollen wir doch
auf den richtigen Soundtrack hoffen.
* Heavy Metal *
(Ja, ja, Burki. Was ist das?)
- (Slayer.)
(Ich habe Musik vermisst.)
- (Und ich war oben.)
Jetzt kam etwas Ehrgeiz auf.
Ich habe Freude.
Ich bin mega entspannt.
Jetzt muss ich nur darauf achten,
dass ich ruhig atme,
damit ich nachher total
entspannt bin, wenn sie hochkommen.
Ich atme wieder ganz normal.
Wir haben es geschafft. Das ist
der höchste Punkt unserer Wanderung.
Es war eigentlich easy,
es sind nur 300 Höhenmeter.
Es war am Schluss doch noch recht
steil. Ich bin froh um eine Pause.
Ich bin William Wallace
und ich kämpfe
für die Freiheit von Schottland!
Schaut euch
diese Bastarde von Engländern an!
Ich habe kalte Hände.
Wir lassen sie uns nicht nehmen,
unsere Ländereien, unsere Frauen,
unsere Playstations,
unsere Rasenmäher!
Wir lassen ...
Du bist ja gar nicht geschminkt.
Was?
- Du brauchst eine Kriegsbemalung.
Ich habe einfach kalte Hände.
Ist es furchteinflössend?
- Mega.
Ziehen wir in den Krieg!
- Ja.
Ah!
- Yeah!
* Manu schreit. *
Manu?
* Manu schreit weiter. *
Scheisse!
Freiheit!
- Gut, dann mache ich den Ton.
* Lockere Musik:
"I'm On My Way" von The Proclaimers *
Ich finde auch,
der Film ist ein absoluter Knaller.
Aber ich wäre nicht
auf die Idee gekommen,
ihn während des Wanderns
nachzuspielen
und bei 3 °C und 140 Knoten Wind
die Szene 1 1/2 Std. nachzuspielen.
Aber es war sehr lustig.
So sind wir. Logisch,
manchmal habe ich eine Idee,
manchmal hat auch
der andere eine Idee.
Und einer ist nicht gerade Fan
und begeistert davon.
Aber ich finde es cool, dass wir
dem anderen den Gefallen machen.
Es hat sich fast immer gelohnt.
(Wir können sagen, ihm ist
nichts passiert, er sitzt hier.)
(Schwenk!)
- (Zeig ihn mal!)
(Das ist Tom,
er macht den Ton und er lebt.)
(Tom-Ton!)
(Genau! Aber dieser verdammte Weg
wollte nicht aufhören.)
(Ich wurde so wütend.)
- (Du hast falsch gerechnet.)
(Ich habe das Team
zusammengeschissen.)
Der Weg geht so.
Der ganze Tag wäre 11 km,
und jetzt sind wir bei 18 km.
Das ist für den Kopf nicht gut.
Diese Stimmung spürt nun Hänsu.
Tut mir leid,
aber das pisst mich an.
Ich habe die Höhenlinien gesehen,
aber es geht ja um den Weg.
Es ist nicht das erste Mal.
Es ist schon zweimal passiert.
Wir sagten, es sei sehr lange.
Der letzte Kilometer
und wir sputen uns ...
Jetzt sind wir hier
hinuntergerannt
und sind seit 1 1/2 Std. unterwegs.
Normalerweise
machen wir 2,5 km in 30 Min.
Scheisskarte, Scheissland,
Scheisskaff da unten!
Abstellen, fortwerfen, zertrampeln!
Der Mist ist: Man kann uns
mit unserer Gesichtsbemalung
im Moment nicht ernst nehmen.
(Ja, wir sind dann wirklich
in dieses Kaff.)
(Kinlochleven - nomen est omen.
Es ist wirklich ein Loch.)
(Ein Kinnloch!)
- (Ein grosses Loch.)
(Ich blieb gleich wütend.)
(Aber traurig!)
Ich bin das erste Mal
etwas erledigt.
Ich bin immer noch geschminkt.
Ich bin echt erledigt.
Heute war die Etappe sehr weit.
Und, äh ...
Ich habe es unterschätzt.
Das ist Kacke!
Ich bin etwas steil hineingegangen.
Jetzt sind wir
nur noch zwei Tage unterwegs,
aber momentan
habe ich es nicht im Griff,
dass ich es easy nehmen könnte.
Es ist so ... ah ...
Hoffentlich geht das noch.
* Sphärischer Gesang *
* "A Ghaoil, Leig Dhachaigh
Gum Mh Thair Mi" von Julie Fowlis *
(Das war der zweitletzte Wandertag.
Das weiss ich noch.)
(Total verlassen.)
(Genau! Mein Fotospeicher war voll.)
(Und dein Wanderakku leer.)
(Stimmt.)
* Sphärischer Gesang *
Wir sind ein Stück weit froh,
dass wir es bald geschafft haben.
Ein Stück weit?
- Ein Stück weit.
Hier gemütlich vor dem Chalet Edel-
weiss zu sitzen, finde ich schön.
Wieder einmal ein gesundes Picknick.
Aber es ist jetzt dann genug.
Seit gestern Abend ist die Luft
etwas draussen, auch körperlich.
Heute bin ich am Kämpfen,
obwohl es ein easy day ist.
Ich freue mich auf zu Hause.
(Zweistimmig)
# Luegid, vo Bärg und vo Tal
# flieht scho der Sunnestrahl.
# Luegid, vo Aue und Matte
# wachse die dunkele Schatte.
# D'Sunn uf de Bärge no stoht.
# Oh, wie sind d'Gletscher so rot.
(Hier hätten wir zelten sollen,
und es stürmte so stark.)
Vielleicht wird es doch noch was
mit dieser Schwitzhütte.
(Die Schwitzhütte!)
- (Wieder so ein blöder Furz! Nein!)
Legt man die so rein?
- Ja.
Werden die nicht gesprengt?
- Doch, das kann passieren.
Kannst du mir sicherheitsmässig
eine blaue Brille anmalen?
(Wir haben noch
ein Geschenk bekommen.)
So geil!
So geil! Das ist echt geil.
Du bist ein Idiot!
Vielen Dank.
Ich bin froh, denn ich habe seit
fünf Tagen dieselben Unterhosen an.
* Schwungvolle Musik *
Wenn das wie ein Dampfbad ist,
ist das super für die Haut.
Ich habe so viele Pickel bekommen.
Erstickst du?
Der Rauch
brennt extrem in den Augen.
(Irgendetwas lief schief.)
(Es hat uns die Lungen verätzt.)
(Wir sind erstickt.)
Ich habe ihn ja gerne
für solche Sachen, immer gute Ideen.
* Würgen, Husten *
Oh, ist das heiss!
* Husten, Spucken *
Kommst du?
- Das war deine Idee.
3 1/2 Std. haben wir
den Scheiss aufgebaut.
Jetzt sitzen wir 10 Min. rein,
auch wenn wir nachher tot sind.
Ich glaube, auf Dauer
ist das gesundheitsschädigend.
Ich würde in 5 Min.
noch etwas Wasser dazugeben.
Aber nur noch einmal.
* Dynamische Musik *
Aua!
Jetzt hält man es langsam aus.
Es riecht zwar noch
nach verbrannter Erde,
aber es ist nicht mehr so schlimm.
Am Schluss
war es wirklich zum Aushalten.
Es war nicht schlecht.
Ich will es zu Hause
noch einmal versuchen.
Ich nehme an,
es ist die verbrannte Erde,
die einen ekligen Geschmack
verbreitet hat.
(Wir hatten beide noch zwei Tage
ein Brennen in der Lunge.)
Konntest du schlafen?
- Nein!
Gleich schlecht wie die erste Nacht,
aber heute ist es mir egal.
Auf nach Fort William!
Der letzte Tag unterwegs -
ich verstehe es noch nicht ganz.
Zuerst müssen wir uns
jetzt aufraffen.
Nach einer
einmal mehr miserablen Nacht
bin ich trotzdem gut gelaunt,
weil es jetzt wirklich
dem Ende entgegengeht.
Jetzt sind wir genug gewandert.
* Sanfte Musik *
* "I'm Gonna Be" von George MacKay,
Antonia Thomas, Peter Mullan *
(Ja!)
- (Hier ist es.)
(Unser Ziel - Fort William.)
Die ersten 3 km haben wir
in etwa 12 Min. gemacht.
Ich bin ganz nass und habe
nasse Schottenunterhosen an.
Wir haben ein rasantes Tempo drauf.
Aber jetzt spitzt es sich zu,
weil wir uns sehr auf das Ende
dieser langen Wanderung freuen.
Andiamo! Che cosa ...
Si, si, va bene!
Hier ist es, Burki.
Hier:
The End of the West Highland Way.
Ja, nein, nein!
Die Stöcke kannst du haben.
Wegen dieser lausigen Statue!
- Ich brauche sie nicht mehr.
Ich gratuliere dir.
Seit zweieinhalb Wochen trage ich
das Glengoyne-Gebräu mit mir.
Und das gibt es jetzt.
Wir haben heute noch darüber geredet
und ich habe Respekt davor,
ob wir es körperlich schaffen mit
einem Rucksack, bei diesem Wetter,
154 km quer
durch die Wildnis zu wandern.
Das Erlebnis zählt. Und einmal
durchhalten, ist immer gesund.
Ich bin glücklich,
ich bin sehr glücklich.
Weisst du,
was wir noch machen könnten?
Wenn das Fläschchen leer ist,
legen wir einen Wunsch hinein,
den wir für die nächsten zehn Jahre
haben, und werfen es ins Meer.
Sehr schön. Das machen wir.
Etwas esoterisch,
aber nicht schlecht.
Das ist nostalgisch, romantisch.
(Weisst du noch,
was du aufgeschrieben hast?)
(Eins von zwei weiss ich noch.)
(Ich auch nur noch das eine.)
So!
Ist es möglich, dass wir
ohne Rucksäcke ans Meer runtergehen?
Gut?
- Gut, ich bin dabei.
(Es war super. Kalt und nass.)
(Sehr.)
(Ich denke gerne daran zurück.)
- (Es gab coole Momente.)
(Apropos kalt und nass -
du hast Schottland gewünscht.)
(Ja, das ist auf meinem Mist
gewachsen. Das stimmt.)
(Und ...
das dürfen wir jetzt sagen:
Die wollen wieder
so etwas mit uns machen.)
(Und ich meinte dann, nach nass
und kalt und Schottland ...
... jetzt darf ich wünschen.)
(Das machen wir nächstes Jahr.)
(2017 wird für uns wieder gross,
wir sind dann wieder unterwegs.)
(Dann aber an der Wärme!
Ich freue mich jetzt schon.)
("Wärme" ist nett ausgedrückt.)
- (In der Hitze! Juhui!)
(Wie gehen mit demselben Team
wieder für drei Wochen.)
(Dieses Mal aber nach Spanien.
Und zwar nach Andalusien.)
(Ich freue mich.)
(Schönen Abend
und ein gutes neues Jahr.)
(Salut.)
- (Tschüss.)
SWISS TXT / UT-Redaktion Zürich
Alexandra Duttweiler - 2016